the economy is in shambles foreign
policy is falling apart the border is
completely porous and the vast majority
of americans hate the direction the
country is going in bad news for the
country
very good news though for republicans
who are looking at the midterm elections
because
people want a change well what does that
mean what is a republican congress even
going to do
to help me answer that question i am
joined by my friend the congresswoman
from colorado's third congressional
district lauren bobert lauren thank you
for joining me thank you so much michael
this is great this is a little bit of a
makeshift studio you know we've got a
ton of construction going on at daily
wire so the best they could do is a
couch and a couple of cameras you know
this is fantastic i like the chaos i'm a
restaurant owner and a mom of four boys
so chaos and dysfunction it's kind of
been a part of my life for a long time
that's why dc works so well for me too
yeah i had i had to wonder you you know
you already you take on a lot you got a
nice family you know you're
working very hard and you said i want to
make my life even crazier
go
join congress right what was i thinking
um no i i i want to preserve our
freedoms for for the next generations i
was looking at my boys and i did not
want to send them into a socialist
nation and so this is me stepping up
stepping up to do my part to serve my
country to preserve freedoms for my
children and and so many other children
here in our country we live in the
greatest nation in the world and there
are so many people who want to destroy
it we've seen it in the past two years
more than ever before uh so i'm very
excited that i that i did get in this um
and i do believe it's for the right
reasons uh to preserve liberty to
preserve what our founding fathers had
intended and uh it's really been a great
journey so
that sounds great that's good i like
that i like all conservative sounding
stuff but what are the nuts and bolts
what does that mean right now the
republicans have zero power in the house
of representatives if
barring some act of god that completely
changes the polling the republicans are
going to retake the house in november
i have two questions actually sure one
what do you think the
republican majority should do
and two what do you think the republican
majority is actually going to do they're
very different there it is yes so um
we're five votes short right now in the
house and so nancy pelosi controls
congress with five votes it's really
frustrating even when she loses five or
six votes when the squad says no no no
we're we're not going to vote for
infrastructure because we want bill back
better first we want to spend 5 trillion
before the 1 trillion even when she
loses them there's still some
republicans that put their hand up and
say don't worry nancy we'll pass this
for you
so that's been really frustrating but
when we take back the the house in 2023
i think we should be leading on
investigations
this has to be a priority for us we
don't know what the senate is going to
look like joe biden is in the basement
of the white house or at some faux set i
think is set as a kind of makeshift like
this one
only uh only slightly less artificial
looking black box with a tv screen right
yes exactly what i mean why not when he
only has the real white house to do
press conferences so i mean
i don't blame him uh but so he he'll
still be there and uh the the senate we
don't know what that will look like i
would love to take it back but we'll see
um so i think that we really need to put
pressure on these investigations
oversight committee needs to be holding
investigations into nih into fauci
into the origins of covet 19 into the
southern border
michael there's a complete invasion two
million people have come into our
country illegally we're seeing where
biden is filling up airplanes and
sending people all throughout our
country in the middle of the night but
that's also taking place during the day
too i've been at the mcallen airport
i've seen dozens of groups of people
boarding these airplanes and going
anywhere in america they say they know
someone and so investigations are going
to be key
and we've we've heard current leadership
say that this is what we will do
but i don't know if we'll be able to
actually
get legislation all the way through so
we need to be holding people as
accountable um to to all of these things
that are destroying our country right
now i like that because it's a realistic
answer you're not going to get any laws
through
it certainly not if there's not a
republican majority in the senate and
and even if there is joe biden's just
going to shoot it down anyway or or
whoever his successor is depending on if
he makes it through the next few years
so
the the what the congress can do is
investigate yes and even at that point
there's there's not even a ton that the
congress can do in terms of prosecuting
but at the very least congress can bring
some some of this corruption to life
absolutely
i'm very much looking forward to doing
exactly that bringing these
investigations forward uh and bringing
people and subpoena issuing subpoenas to
get people to answer uh to congress but
also if we have the house
there are several articles of
impeachment um one of my own that i have
introduced for joe biden
joe biden needs to be impeached for his
dereliction of duty to keep america safe
the keep safe act and this invasion
that's taking place at um our southern
border afghanistan that horrible
withdrawal that's uh actually what my
articles are um in reference to um the
the drone strike that killed tennessee
10 innocent civilians the 13 service
members that died 86 billion dollars in
our military equipment left behind uh
all of these things i don't know what he
left more of uh
american citizens right american
military equipment or american pride now
do you think one of the arguments during
the trump
i was going to say impeachments but it's
it's multiple impeachments right not
just the impeachment multiple
one of the issues was that the
conservatives and even some civil
libertarians said
well you you can't impeach a president
for mal administration he might be a
really bad president but that's not an
impeachable offense you've got to
impeach for high crimes and misdemeanors
do you think that anything biden has
done has risen to that level absolutely
especially when you look to afghanistan
um he was taking orders from terrorists
and uh and left our
people behind left our allies behind and
this has put us in a in a horrible
situation our enemies no longer fear us
and our allies can no longer trust us
and now look at what's taking place with
russia and
ukraine at this would never have
happened under president trump um and
it's because we do not have real
leadership right now and then uh the
southern border you know i think the
most interesting part of all of this is
construction was canceled on january
20th of of 2021 and
joe biden is not saving any american
citizen any tax money by canceling this
construction we are spending five
million dollars a day
in government contracts for a wall that
is not being built right five million
dollars a day and and all the while 2
million people are pouring into our
country but you're even starting to hear
more of the moderate republicans talk
about impeachment and this is this is
getting really serious um
we do not have strong leadership in the
white house now since you bring up the
moderate republicans
tell me about the factionalism i want to
go back to high school i want to know
about the cliques and the popular kids
and the the divisions because when the
republicans retake the house
we're going to need to see who's leading
there are a lot of disagreements among
republicans and so which faction is
going to come out on top you're a member
of the house freedom caucus yes i am
there are other moderate republicans who
are either not members of the freedom
caucus or who actively dislike the
freedom caucus so what does that look
like
well so first of all i love that you
said we are going to need to see who's
leading on the issues and i think that
is the most important thing for when
we're in the majority everyone wants to
know who's going to be speaker who's
going to be whip who's in these
leadership positions in the conference i
want to see who is leading on the issues
and this year i have seen the house
freedom caucus leading on the issues and
so i'm very uh excited to be a part of
this group this is the one group in
congress that actually gets together
regularly
and debates the constitutionality of
everything that we do the the votes that
we're taking the procedures that that
we're executing on the house floor
everything that we're doing we are
including the constitution in our
conversations and our arguments as to
why we're doing it and if we can't find
our
our answer there then we seek god and so
it's a really great uh group to be a
part of uh you know we we just had a
change in leadership uh we now have
scott perry who is the chairman andy
biggs was the chairman before that jim
jordan and mark mark meadows so it's a
really great group um but being with
them being with such principled people
who put the country first who put people
first and put god first it's really
incredible um and not everyone likes us
um i'm okay with that though you know
i'm okay with you know being called a a
performance artist i mean what are we
going to do in in the minority uh i i am
a mouthpiece right now for so many
people who feel disadvantaged who feel
like government is is so big and so
over-encompassing that is it destroying
every aspect of their life that they are
trying so hard to just keep together and
uh
i said on the campaign trail if we are
silent we lose by default so if i have
to be dramatic and loud to get the
message out then so be it right i think
politics has always had a little
theatricality to it you know jumping out
of airplanes so
was that a veiled no i don't know i just
can't hold on i can't well this this
actually
the reason it matters the kind of
clickiness and the different factions
is because one of the groups that
historically doesn't play that well with
the freedom caucus is house republican
leadership
so these are the people who are setting
the agenda who are whipping the votes
what does that relationship look like
right now well right now we are in the
minority so we we do see a lot of people
leaning more conservative than we will
in the majority
because there's no stakes correct so you
can you can make a lot of noise and say
well but the moment you actually have to
start passing legislation or calling
investigations yes then things change
right and and i really hope that they
don't i hope that this has been a great
awakening
because the democrats have not held back
on anything
like i said they only have a five seat
majority and it is incredible how nancy
controls her conference and gets them
all to vote together
even even some where you think they
would be conservative on energy policies
they would want the keystone xl pipeline
um to to be able to have their permits
back and still they will they follow in
lockstep to nancy pelosi uh and so i
think the republican party has always
had this kind of individual uh
free thinking um
element to it which makes me want to be
a part of it and so i love the
conversations that we have but we need
to be doing what's right for the people
and and not just making excuses to spend
trillions of dollars
and and put our children's future at
risk so um
when it comes to leadership right now um
you know kevin he'll sit down and listen
to us leader mccarthy will sit down and
listen to the freedom caucus when we
have grievances and there's certainly
been a lot of things we were the first
to say liz cheney needs to be removed as
conference chair and we had actually
whipped those votes and we had them but
then unfortunately something happened um
and and we didn't have the votes anymore
and then she was she was able to stay in
this position further damaging leader
mccarthy the conference the party
and and then just a few weeks later
maybe three months later um
everyone else realized oh wait she
shouldn't be in this position we're like
yes we told you so right right she was
the gop caucus chairman now most of her
leadership is spent on
cnn or msnbc or nancy pelosi's sham
january 6th committee yes exactly now
it's not just that there is some
infighting among the republicans
there's a bigger fight which is
against the democrats absolutely one
thing i've noticed lauren is that uh of
all my friends who are in politics
you tend to trend them not if not the
most you're certainly up there right you
tren anything you say yes the democrats
get very upset about there was one thing
you said in particular you made a joke
thought it was a perfectly fine
lighthearted joke right about ilhan omar
ilhan omar has said
supportive things about terrorist
organizations she has giggled
naming al-qaeda and other terrorist
organizations and you made a joke and
you said you know ilhan omar you know is
probably friends with terrorists or
whatever she's probably paling around
with terrorists right
this you became you were hitler you're
an you're david duke you're the worst
bigot in the world
right it seems a little disingenuous
it does but uh you know i
ilhan omar she demanded an apology for
me and i i i finally got her on the
phone it took several days to get her to
actually communicate with me i got her
on the phone and i told her i said look
none of this should ever be about
someone's faith
but i i do believe that there is a time
where you need to apologize to the
american people my apology wasn't good
enough for her they said if there's
going to be a statement made it's
from you to the american people for your
anti-american anti-semitic anti-police
rhetoric this is this is what is
destroying our country she absolutely is
anti-semitic and everything that she
says and does um i mean even accusing
leader mccarthy for supporting israel
because of money she said it's all about
the benjamin's right uh you know
didn't she say something to the effect
of
please allow allah to uh open the eyes
of the people to the evils of his yes
yeah okay this is a
little on the nose yes yes like they
were being brainwashed and uh yes
but uh and then and then of course she
wants to go on tv and cry saying that
she received death threats okay look
that's terrible i get them every single
day to my office any time when a public
figure complains about death threats
i tune it out i just turn it off because
i i think it's so it's not dishonest in
that i'm sure they're getting death
threats right every single person who is
in public life gets death threats if you
have more than i don't know
50 000 followers on twitter you know i'm
not saying you're a member of congress
or just if you just have any public
platform you get death threats
absolutely that goes it's not good it's
bad it's unfortunate but to to bring
that up the moment that you're called
out on some of your bs or something
vicious that you've done yes to play the
victim and say well i'm getting threats
give me a break absolutely my mom got
death threats because they tried to call
her the bullhorn lady from january 6th
there's some some lady in a pink hat and
she's
hollering at a bullhorn she's like
giving directions to the capitol and
people were saying that this was my
mother my mother was getting death
threats so anyway so she goes on tv
cries plays a little video i'm like i
got seven of those girlfriend like
do you want do you want the ones from
today or all week
but all the while she is the one who
wants to defund dismantle disband our
law enforcement agencies
and so you're crying about
receiving these threats and you want to
get rid of those people who would
protect you now you know i remember when
that happened the hullabaloo happens so
you told an off-color joke i'm sure no
one has ever done that you you suggested
that uh one of your colleagues might
have radical views and associations the
democrats would never do that right joe
biden just called us all nazis and right
but they would never do that and so they
make a big deal
i was so nervous
that you were going to
apologize do one of these public
floggings right no please not you lauren
no i know a lot of squishes would do but
not you lauren and then you made the
apology a demand that she apologized
right i loved that yes yes i did i did
demand that she um apologized and and
you know to to the muslim community this
wasn't anything to do with them this is
ilhan omar in her radical extremist
views right um which which i don't think
uh i don't think we really discuss
enough aoc gets a lot of the attacks a
lot of people point to her as the leader
of the squad but i mean
i kind of think it's ill
and and isn't it fair i mean
isn't it fair if you're a member of
congress to ask what do you believe
right are we we're real we're not
allowed to talk i mean obviously
politics has a relation to culture
culture is downstream of religion
or
thoughts on the i'm not saying there
ought to be a religious test for some
office but surely the things that we
believe about morality about ethics
about the nation about the relationship
of the citizen to to the polity
these are important questions they're
totally free they're only fair when it
comes from the democrats though it's not
when the republicans do it you're not
allowed to to ask them right everything
is a double standard um you know it's
interesting
gosh look at
the ukraine call that joe biden just had
talk about a double standard release the
transcripts what's going on with that
call um when president trump
uh talked to uh zilinki uh it
they demanded that we release the
transcripts yeah
he released them
so it was impeached
right right
and uh if they could have impeached
trump a third time they would have done
that too over why i don't know because
he put too much ketchup on his steak
right now before i let you go lauren i
know you're very busy
the producers have have put together a
series of images because listen
politicians you politicians you're very
good you've got your answers you know
you've thought through these so i want
your
instant response when you see an image
okay i want the first word that comes to
your mind well i saw my deputy chief
roll his eyes when i said zelinki so
let's say zielinski
okay
zelenke zielenski
i don't even speak ukrainian
more to get to in one second first
though i am sure you know about the ring
video doorbell because i've been telling
you about it for years you know it's
this amazing doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your doorstep
whether you're in the house at the
office on the other side of the world
it's amazing did you know that ring
makes an alarm ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring best
of all you can install it yourself it's
so simple even i can do it i'm not
exactly the handiest guy in the world
but you can it's amazing you can get all
the sensors for motion doors and windows
that will work on any house or apartment
just like yours i love it ring gives me
peace of mind whether i'm away from home
and sweet little alisa and the baby are
there or whether we're all away from
home and you're going to protect your
home against not just the bad guys but
sensors that will help prevent your home
from flood freeze and fire too it's
amazing professional monitoring gives
you the ultimate peace of mind it's
super inexpensive by the way you get
award-winning professional monitoring
for less money per year than you
probably pay for a month of the old kind
of services go get the ring alarm go to
ring.com
mike will get a great deal on a ring
alarm home security kit today ring.com
michael
all right we've got the producers have
put together these i think i haven't
even seen all of these images
just go right off the top of your head
let's go
oh
adam kinzinger's buddy
does she get an oscar too you know
it's more than one word but i'll let it
stand uh one word one word adam
kinzinger's buddy that's good
that counts that's good
do i know her
that's so devastating
the word i was going to say was ringo
ringo does ringo count
not vp
not she's not the vp she's the future
supreme court supreme court of justice
okay
my buddy
yeah aoc is kensinger's buddy and ilhan
is your buddy okay
now who is this i love it i'm so we were
this is he's cancelled from spotify yeah
yeah he's neil young
we were taking bets we were actually
doing we said does anyone know who neil
young is anymore and because the whole
argument neil young goes to spotify and
says all right guys if you don't take
rogan out i'm going and they said yes
don't let the door hit you on the way
out exactly no i followed the story but
no i i don't that was such an edifying
genuine reaction
who is this who is this who's that man
okay we should have we should have done
a pant suit um we should have
done a
a run through of these yep let's pan
suit that's fair fair enough
fake news fake new that's i mean come on
mr president really burns
you can't think of anything else
decaying
you know the house chambers is very very
cold and i am certain it's because we
are preserving her body that's true you
know because formaldehyde might not be
in the budget for but so you turn the
temperature
most platypus hand am i allowed to talk
about
wow
no i think you know tucker was making
fun of some of uh
the speaker's surgeries so i think it's
all fair game yes okay
1776.
let's just roll with it no so you know
what actually i want to talk about that
so
um that day i was so dang excited
to actually put my name to documents to
to have the debate to have the con
the conversation in congress about the
election and to sign my name to these
documents just like our founding fathers
had done and i was so excited when i
woke up that day and the democrats have
taken this and uh they have just it's
the worst attack ever
it's horrible how they can just change
the definitions or run with a narrative
and make so many people think that it's
it's something that it's
that it's not what's what's amazing too
is call it a riot fine you say that
there was broken property sure uh the
only obviously the only
death in the political violence was from
a trigger happy cop at one of them right
right
yeah
but okay fine you say you say there have
been plenty of attacks on the capitol
many yes so this is something yes
exactly so i had just brought this to
the sergeant-at-arms attention um we are
several hundred police officers short at
the capitol right now um
maybe it's because they've been attacked
for the past two years and demonized
but regardless we are several hundred
short and uh i was talking with the
sergeant-at-arms he doesn't want us to
carry our firearms i told him this day
january 6 was the most vulnerable day of
my life because i was disarmed i was not
right i was disarmed i wasn't allowed to
have it in there there's people shaking
the doors and you know i wasn't looking
to my colleagues to the left and right
of me saying
i hope there are enough metal detectors
outside right no i i wanted my firearm
um i didn't know what was on the other
side well anyway so we're having this
conversation and they said you know
i knew before this day that this
building was not secure and this is why
i wanted my firearm in the capitol and
we we know about the bomb outside the
senate chambers we know about uh the the
puerto ricans who came in and shot
inside the house chambers you can look
at the ceiling see the bullet hole you
could look in the desk drawer on the
republican side and see the bullet hole
in the desk drawer
the capitol police officers who were
shot in the head and uh and then and
then people still made it past them
and even recently there was a staffer
who accidentally brought in a firearm it
took 12 minutes for him to be
apprehended and detained right 12
minutes and yet they say despite all of
those past examples they're saying that
the midwestern dad cracking the coors
light in the rotunda that was the
greatest threat to democracy and the re
it's not as though one needs to say this
was the greatest event in the history of
the world you can you can simply point
out it wasn't an insurrection
and
inasmuch as it was an insurrection if
you really insist on using that term not
only was it not the worst insurrection
in history it wasn't the worst
instruction of the year right after
eight months of blm yes yes exactly is
great i love i love that gut reaction to
say bs with this narrative from the left
because so many of the facts that we're
basing this on
turned out to be untrue right and even
the new york times had to admit it yes
and the democrats spent the entire year
normalizing and incentivizing riots and
looting and beating police officers and
yes
yes and bailing them out of jail i mean
yes that's ridiculous all right next one
liar
the devils
fireball
speaking of investigations by the way or
if absolutely you guys retake the house
yeah this guy's getting dragged to
capital daily
great yes great yes we are not relenting
capitol hill or gitmo i settle for
either okay yes
that's it
that's all of them
so uh lauren you're you've in town for a
couple of days then you're back to
washington dc yes
what what when you're looking at uh the
months ahead we're preparing for you'll
have a re-election as a member of
congress we're preparing to retake the
house yes what do the next few months
look like
well for me uh you know there's a lot of
work in district but i've done that uh
all year and it's been some of the most
exciting parts of this job
i go to washington dc i
quarrel with democrats we strategize in
the freedom caucus we put forward
legislation but then i come home and i
travel my 50 000 square mile uh district
and connect with so many people at home
and so that's that's the next few months
for me is a lot of time um in the
district connecting with people we'll
have a primary um you know there's
there's a lot of rhinos that are upset
that i'm doing what i said i would do uh
but i've never heard uh you know a
conservative say you know i just i just
want to elect somebody who's gonna
give in and and relinquish their
principles and back down on day one uh
so you know i i ran as a conservative
because i am a conservative and i'll win
again as a conservative but we have to
keep everyone engaged at all of these
local levels we see the school boards
where parents are taking them over
because we want a say in what our
children are being taught and so i need
everybody to stay engaged stay focused
and and not lose hope
i wouldn't leave my four boys and my
husband every day to do what i'm doing
if i didn't believe that we could turn
this around i would go home but yes i i
know we could do it though that's a
great point you're
giving up something you're really
actually sacrificing something and you
wouldn't do that if all hope were lost
all hope is not laws that's right hope
is a theological virtue and even when
you look at polling right now things are
looking pretty good
lauren thank you for coming by thanks so
much michael all right
[Music]
[Music]